what is the always lost moment the all
as lost moment is when the character is
as far away as possible from achieving
the goal the significance of the All Is
Lost moment is in hitting rock bottom
the character has an epiphany in the
Epiphany is the recognition of the flaw
that is holding them back then the
connection to the character and the
action that they take at the top of the
last act that leads to the achievement
of the goal should reflect the
consciousness of the flaw and
acknowledgment or the denial of the flaw
with the choice that is made that leads
to the resolution
so the All Is Lost moment is so
important in getting the character to
change yes
in in hitting rock bottom it again
universally we all hit our Rock Bottom
moments we all hit our moments where
they say each person has at least three
to four of these moments in life so
these are moments that are identifiable
and when the audience is watching the
character hit rock bottom they're
identifying with what that is and then
when they see the characters awareness
become conscious of the flaw then they
look at their own lives and think about
could I make better choices that could
lead me to a stronger outcome by
acknowledging the flaw so when we see in
story
all the time when it's done well then we
get empowered in our own lives of how we
can transform our All Is Lost moments
into growth opportunity
so that's interesting so you say that
most people will hit three or four all
those last moments does it have anything
to do with age or financial status or
anything it it doesn't because
I have so many people who will say to me
are Young Writers
not
ready when when they're writing and I
said all depends on what happens in
their life if you have a young writer
whose parent died when they were 10.
they become old souls so those are the
types of moments certainly with us going
through what we all went through with
the idea of black lives matter and US
feeling that connection with
um characters that are going through so
much loss that these are life-defining
moments that it's not because they're 25
or their their midlife or they're old
it's because these are things that are
happening to them in the moment that
could be at any life point in any life
phase so these defining moments are are
like turning points that happen in our
life and that can happen at any time and
I think are the phase of life that we're
in determines how our character will
evolve from the choices we make because
of what happened to us
does the All Is Lost moment usually
result from a goal fail like a failure
of a goal
the all Asos moment is like your final
in another thing to think about with the
always lost moment it should always be
due to an action that the character
takes toward the goal versus something
that happens to them so you always want
to think of yes you number one it's so
important that you feel the goal in the
All Is Lost moment that you feel that
the character is as far away as possible
from that achievement and that they are
being active and it's kind of like in
life like you hit a brick wall so many
times before you start to recognize
that's not the way to do it you're
always off lost moment is serving the
same purpose it's telling you your
flawed behavior is getting in the way of
your dream and unless you do something
to change by becoming a more aware and
conscious you are not going to have the
same outcome with the resolution as you
will if you acknowledge what's going on
with the flaw and what's holding you
back
and is the always lost moment the same
as the Dark Night of the Soul
in film there I have like say for
example in a film like Avatar you have
they always lost moment and The Dark
Knight of the soul is two separate
moments in many films they are one in
the same so I think it all depends on
the structure of the film I think there
are plenty of writers where they're
seasoned writers who know how to serve
both but and both are part of the same
type of sequence which is something that
is bringing the character aware of what
is holding them back as it links to the
dream and the goal how long does the All
Is Lost moment last in a story they all
thought well it depends on the story but
it's a it is quick I it is something
where now the All Is Lost sequence could
be something depending on the story that
could feel like it's building from the
midpoint on but ideally you're looking
for the the moment itself is something
where we feel that due to the action
taken they hit the all is awesome moment
and this is something that quickly
happens where they they feel
at wit's end as far as the goal
what if the character refuses to change
then you're having a tragedy then that
that brings you into the idea of a film
that is a tragedy because the character
resists the acknowledgment of the flaw
do you see that with a lot of writers do
they want their characters to change
I see resistance
for the idea that
what we've talked about earlier is that
so many people in their lives
it takes so much before they're willing
to change so
however I feel like when you look at the
idea of change everything's incremental
like you you look at a character who you
say no they'll never change like when
you look at for example when you look at
the comedy and they say in comedy the
character doesn't change yet because now
certainly in streaming when you have the
half hour drama
then you're taking on the component of
the transformation where the character
does change and I even think many
comedies are also now recognizing the
value of
incremental change even if it's not a
massive change but a small change in the
awareness of the character